ماريا آاندا، عالمة من جامعة نيويورك
أبوظبي، تبحث عن مصادر مياه جديدة
وتجمع أدوات بحثها
وهي متجهة إلى الصحراء وهي
هنا لدراسة نبات يزدهر في
هذا المناخ الجاف أنا هنا لدراسة
هذه النباتات الصحراوية المحددة أو ماذا
ماريا مستعدة لترى كيف
تمكنت هذه النباتات وتكيفت
للبقاء على قيد الحياة في واحد من أقسى
المناخات في العالم للعين المجردة، فهي لا
تبدو كثيرة ولكن تحت
كاميرا المجهر اكتشفت ماريا
أعجوبة طبيعية مغطاة بأغصان كاملة  في
الآلاف من
بلورات الملح، تكون بلورات الملح هذه
استرطابية للغاية مما يعني أنها تحب
جذب الماء من الهواء وفي
رطوبة منخفضة جدًا وتتكثف ذلك على
سطح الفرع وهذا
مهم جدًا بالنسبة للبحث الذي
يتم إجراؤه في  المياه لمكافحة
ندرة المياه، لذا فإن الفكرة هي أن لدينا هذه
المواد الصديقة للبيئة التي
تفرزها هذه النباتات، وهذه
البلورات الملحية التي تحب الماء ويمكنها
التقاط الماء من
الهواء، وقد نُشرت النتائج التي توصلت إليها ماريا للتو
في مجلة علمية، وهي تجري
المزيد من الأبحاث لإجراء المزيد من الأبحاث عليها  افعل ذلك ولكنني
واثق من أنه بعد العثور على
نبات صحراوي يمكنه الاستفادة من المياه من
الهواء، سيكون لذلك آثار إيجابية
على أمننا المائي. لقد
اكتشفنا الآن هذا
النظام الطبيعي، لذا هذا هو الأمر، كيف
يمكنك وضع هذا موضع الاستخدام العملي، كيف  لقد
نشرت أنه في العالم الحقيقي،
يمكننا صنعها بسهولة في المختبر،
ويمكننا صنع أجهزة صغيرة باستخدام هذه
الساليست لجذب الماء والتقاطه من
الهواء إذا أردنا إلقاء نظرة على
الصورة الأكبر إذا أردنا التعامل مع
الماء على سبيل المثال  أزمة نحتاج إلى الكثير من
الماء، لذا ما نعتقده هو أن
هذه الأملاح قد تلعب دورًا في
تلقيح السحب والفكرة في تلقيح السحب
بسيطة جدًا، حيث يقومون برشها في الهواء
في السحب، وستلتقط تلك الأملاح
بعض الماء من الهواء
سوف تنمو القطرات بشكل أكبر ثم
تتساقط على الأرض على شكل
أمطار وترسيب وما يجعل
هذه النباتات مميزة للغاية هو أنها
قادرة على جذب وتكثيف
الماء عند مستويات رطوبة منخفضة لا تفعلها حقًا
تحتاج إلى الكثير من الماء في الهواء
لتتكثف، حتى لو كان لديك عدد قليل جدًا من
قطرات الماء في الهواء، فسيتم
جمعها بواسطة ملح
[موسيقى] خاص